don't let your kids do anything it makes  you not like them it's good to have  boundaries or your kids are unhappy  putting them to bed on time no i don't  want to go to bed okay if you don't go  to bed you're going to be upset tomorrow  you're going to wreck your day and you  need to go to sleep because it's healthy  for your brain that is a boundary you're  going to bed no questions asked if  you're very very firm with your rules  and you don't move them ever kids  especially little kids follow those  rules if you end up moving them you're  like yeah okay well tonight you can stay  up or if they push a certain number of  times they'll be like please please  please please please please please  please get to seven you're like ah  fine next time they'll just move their  level to seven so seven will be the  minimum times they ask for something so  have firm boundaries